- My body is ready to eat
bunch of food!
Uh, uh, uh.
(upbeat music)
- We are here at Bon Shabu
in Koreatown Los Angeles.
We're back to do some
spicy food challenge here.
- Oh, right
(laughing)
I was just ready for lunch.
- So you've never tried hot pot?
- I've never had hot pot before.
- Wow.
- Just in general you've
never had a hot pot.
- So I'm really glad that I'm starting
it out with a spicy challenge.
(dramatic music)
- [Man] All right so
we've got meat, seafood,
broth, veggies, sauce.
- Five dishes, this is like a feast,
there's everything you need here.
- [Middle Woman] I'm gonna
bring everyone I've ever known
to eat all this food.
- You know what we should do?
We should do a challenge where
one person eats all of it.
- Yeah, YB is just nominating herself.
- [Man] Apparently, the
white one's the spicier one.
- Which is weird cause this
doesn't look spicy at all.
- [Man] let's try the broth first,
let's try the mild one first.
- Hot!
- Mm, it's great
- It's kinda sweet
- Yeah, it's kinda like...
like Udon soup.
- It is good, although it's
very hot; my tongue burned.
- [Man] Alright, now the spicy one.
- [Middle Woman] I smell the spicy,
it smells almost like jalapeño.
- That's what I was gonna say,
yeah it smells like jalapeño.
- Ooh, oh wow.
- Oh!
(laughing)
- That's pretty spicy.
- That went like straight up.
- A lot of spicy food that we
eat, usually just takes time
this was just like...
- Hits you in the face immediately,
but then it slides down your throat
and then hits you in the
back of the throat, too.
And you're like, full on
mouth explosion of spice.
Oh, I like it.
- [Man] Alright, let's put some food in.
(upbeat music)
Oh this broth is, it's spicy yet so good.
- It's really good, yeah.
- I can't stop drinking it.
It's for sure, like I
could smell and taste that
it's based off of peppers,
jalapenos, green peppers.
It goes so well with the meat.
The meat soaks in the soup,
the broth really well.
- This is the opposite of every
other challenge we've done.
- You like actually want to keep going.
- You're like I want to stop.
- If I came here with my
friends I would get the mild.
- Really?
I'd get the spicy.
That or I'd get one of each,
so I'd have other friends
that are lame that get the other one.
- She's the lame friend, right?
- Yeah she's the lame one.
- Noo! I'm just closer to it.
- Oooh!
- I like watching Evan suffer, it's funny.
- Evan crying is the best.
(laughing)
- I've never heard YB be
that brutal on camera before.
- I kind of doubted it
when it was white, oh man.
- If you're not into spicy
food, this would be so spicy.
- Yeah, I love the pain
when I eat spicy food.
It's kind of weird.
- It's a little weird.
- It's okay I like pain too.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Is this now becoming
an eating challenge?
Like can we finish all of
this between the three of us?
- Hell yeah!
(laughing)
- YB's like that's what I wanted.
- Challenge number two.
Is this all you can eat?
- Yes this all you can eat.
- I don't know, is it
all you can eat meat too?
- Yeah everything's all you can eat.
- Wow!
(upbeat music)
- [Right Woman] Spice wise...
It was...
you can handle it, you know
it's not like a dying spice.
Still very spicy, it
kicks you in the throat
in the beginning.
- Delicious?
Yes.
Spicy?
- A man of few words, our Evan.